We've learned even more about the relationship between age
and friend count by making use of the variables' gender
and tenure. We've seen that users who have been
on the site longer, typically have higher friend counts across
ages. Now, this leaves me wondering if friend requests
are the same or different across groups. Do new users
go on friending sprees? Or do users with more
tenure initiate more friendships? Let's explore this with a plot.
I want you to create a line
graph of friendships initiated per day, versus tenure.
You need to make use of the variables
age, tenure, friendships initiated, and year_joined.bucket. The color
of each part of your one line should
correspond to each bucket of year_joined. You'll also
need to subset the data to only consider users with at least one day of tenure.